[Musique]
j'ignore quelle opinion vous avez sur
l'instruction
moi je me félicite d'être il les traits
[Musique]
fin juin dernier à l'école de delphine
et de marinette c'était la distribution
des prix prix d'excellence mademoiselle
delphine prix d'honneur mademoiselle
marinette et maintenant la parole est à
monsieur le sous-préfet les chers
enfants
l'instruction est une bonne chose et
ceux qui n'en n'ont pas son bien à
plaindre
heureusement vous n'êtes pas dans ce cas
là par exemple je vois ici de petites
filles aux cheveux blonds en robe bleue
elles ont bien travaillé aujourd'hui
elles sont récompensées de leur peine
est allé moi qui vous parle je ne
voudrais pas avoir l'air de me vanter
mais enfin si je n'avais pas toujours
bien appris la leçon je n'aurai pas ma
position de sous préfet ni l'api
d'argent que vous me voyez voilà
pourquoi il faut bien s'appliquer à
l'école et faire comprendre aux
ignorants et aux paresseux que
l'instruction est indispensable
[Musique]
il a rudement bien parler tout à fait
forcément à ce spectacle c'est bien
parce qu'il est sur l'inscription vous
préférez toujours la vérité je te dise
alors comme de droite la corse
fabrication à lorient d'après delphine a
eu le prix d'excellence et marinette le
prix d'honneur d'autres lieux c'est très
bien
les sous-préfets nous a dit que
l'instruction est une bonne chose
il a eu raison nous nous demandons si
maman et toi avez un final struction
nous en avons bien assez pour notre
situation
si nous donnions des leçons pendant les
vacances et moi si je te donne une gifle
tout de suite
[Musique]
mes parents sont comme ça à tout savoir
à qui pourront nous donner des leçons
mais pourquoi me parler tu à l'oreille
j'ai dans la commenter mais c'était pour
rire
j'ai une idée
eh ben on va vous parler
nous venons de labourer et nous sommes
un peu fatigués bapes bapes bapes
apprendre à lire
l'instruction est une belle somme
apprendre à lire pour quoi faire
est-ce que la charrue rang sera moins
lourde à tirer est ce que j'en ai
davantage à manger certainement non je
me fatiguerai donc sans résultat merci
bien
je suis pas si bête que vous croyez
petit nom je n'apprendrai pourra lire ma
foi non mais tu ne parles pas
raisonnablement que tu ne penses pas ce
que tu perds quand les chauffeurs c'est
tout réfléchi mais belle je refuse je ne
suis pas un mauvais bof j'ai toujours
bien fait mon travail
personne n'a rien à me reprocher
remarquez que je ne dis pas de mal de
l'instruction je prétends que ce n'est
pas une chose pour les me voilà tout
certainement il est toujours de mon avis
non pas du tout où as tu pris ça je suis
tout à fait capable de réfléchir pas moi
même at on situe à la folie des
grandeurs
nous on veut je n'ai pas la folie des
grandeurs mais je suis très touchée de
la proposition des petites
sans compter qu'un peu d'ambition ne
fait de mal à personne après tout si
l'instruction n'est pas utile à un boeuf
elle n'est pas une gêne non plus et à
l'occasion elle pourra me distraire si
la chose ne me donne pas trop de
tintouin je consens donc à essayer de
briller en effet
je crois bien que j'ai des dispositions
et dites moi petit
est ce que vous n'avez pas envie
d'apprendre à ruminer apprendre à
ruminer vous avez raison
pour quoi faire
les petites qui voulait faire une
surprise à leurs parents décidèrent de
garder le secret sur les études du boeuf
blanc elle s'installait pour leurs
élèves une sorte de pupitre dans les
tables pour qu'il puisse travailler
commodément eux
les débuts furent plus facile que les
petites n'avait osé l'espérer leboeuf
blanc était vraiment très doué et
d'autre part il avait beaucoup d'amour
propre
ouah en moins de quinze jours il apprit
à lire ces lettres les dimanches les
jours de pluie est en général tous les
soirs au retour des champs delphine et
marinette lui donner des leçons en
cachette de leurs parents nous allons
commencer à apprendre des mots écoute et
répète c'est h à chat chanco69 un ca non
il faudrait un thé pourquoi on sait pas
aller ce mois continuer ses achats chat
est un chat parue cet extraordinaire
photo dr c'est déjà assez compliqué
comme ça
ce que vous pouviez me laisser dormir tu
n'imagines raja mais quel plaisir donne
l'instruction je me sens déjà un autre
buzz qu'il y à trois semaines quel
bonheur d'apprendre mais voilà tout le
monde ne peut pas il faut des capacités
le voyant ainsi heureux leboeuf rouen
venait parfois se demander s'il avait
été sage de s'obstiner dans son
ignorance mais comme cette année là le
fourrage avait un excellent goût de
noisette
il résistait facilement aux séductions
de l'esprit à voir ou ne pas savoir
[Musique]
bon et je pu vivre si longtemps en il y
aura tant de choses
au bout d'un mois delphine et marinette
purent se féliciter de leur initiative
leboeuf lisez couramment et comment
c'est à savoir compter combien font
cette fois huit
donnez votre langue au chat
je le sais ça fait 56 7 en août a dit
roger
malheureusement les études de fatigue et
beaucoup le boeuf à cause de son trop
grand elle est aussi parce que ce
nouveau labeur ne lui épargne et pas
celui des champs le pire était que dans
sa soif de s'instruire il en oubliait la
moitié du temps de boire et de manger
il se dépêche de rentrer pour apprendre
je lui trouve mauvaise mine
il est où paul oui même pour un boeuf
blanc n'est pas
[Musique]
qu'est-ce que tu apprends des poèmes
veut nous sommes très contentes de ton
travail tu en sais maintenant presque
temps nous et peut-être plus mais qu'un
mérite est opposé c'est d'ailleurs tu
affrontes à l'exil je me moque de ma
santé et ne veux penser qu'à hornu mon
esprit puisque tu ne veux pas te reposer
fait attention à ce que personne ne doit
étudier si non parentes surprenait on
peut juger par cette recommandation que
les deux blondes n'était plus très sûr
d'avoir fait oeuvre de sagesse et en
effet des incidents fâcheux se
multiplièrent qu'est ce que tu fais la
meuf est dans cette position assise
j'admire assis sous un portail reste
deux jours dont c'est clair la dernière
heure du travail de qu'est ce que tu dis
ceux de victor hugo
chez pascal boeuf plan il a des airs
singulier ils viennent me dire du victor
hugo et je crois même que c'était des
verts est encore qu il occupe ses
loisirs comme il l'entend je veux bien
mais même quand ils travaillent
qu'est ce qui a de robinet coule dans un
récipient cylindrique de 75 cm de haut
et des beats ensemble 25 centimètres
cubes à la minute
qu'est ce que tu racontes sachant que
l'un des deux robinets s'il coule et
seuls m haies 30 minutes à remplir leurs
récipients c'est pas possible tu es
malade ni moi ce qui ne va pas c'est
tout de même malheureux il n'y a pas
moyen de réfléchir en paix on ne
s'appartient pas on dirait que je n'ai
pas d'autre à faire que la charrue faux
j'en ai par dessus la tête du joug tu
m'inquiètes tu sais c'est bon j'ai été
distrait n'en parlons plus de robinet
coule dans un récipient de 75 cm et se
nomme deux mois c'est pas croyable
non seulement il fait son travail de
travers mais il répond comme le pire des
effrontées ainsi continuer à se rendre
insupportable voit obligé de le vendre
pour la boucherie pour quoi faire
obtient cette idée pour le manger tout
simplement mangé le boeuf blanc je ne
veux pas ni moi on ne mange pas pas
parce qu'il est de mauvaise humeur parce
qu'il est pris il faudrait peut-être le
consoler taisez-vous de personnel que
vous êtes
ces choses là ne regarde pas les gamines
si notre bac ne s'amendent pas ils sont
à manger comme il le mérite
elles sont sensibles
en fait de leur âge s'il fallait les
écouter mais on est stressé toutes les
bêtes mourir de vieillesse
quant aux boeufs blanc je ne crois pas
qu'il soit possible de le vendre à barra
en tant qu' du si maigre que ce serait
une mauvaise affaire
je serais tout de même curieux de savoir
pourquoi il a maigri ainsi j'ai toujours
pensé que ce n'était pas naturel
[Musique]
oui
avec la voix râble participe passé reste
invariable s'il n'a pas donc je ne
dirais tu continues à mal tirer la
charrue et à répondre d'autres à vertu
va être vendu que m'apporte fillette
là dessus je suis de l'avis de la
fontaine notre ennemi c'est notre maître
s'est pas vendu pour pas parce que tu
étais là voyez comme il est à présent et
ne connais plus ni parents ni amis que
m'apporte d'être vendus le seul risque
serait sans doute de me voir apprécier
un peu mieux que je ne le suis ici tu
serais bandiougou sait et ce serait ne
peut pas nous abandonner la fonction si
tu ne veux pas être manger il faut que
tu commences par oublier avait bien dit
que ça ne valait rien pour les bleus
sachez que je ne regrette rien et que je
refuse d'oublier quoi que ce soit ma
seule ambition est d'apprendre encore et
toujours
plutôt mourir que d'y renoncer ça
m'ennuierait te perdre sans crottés que
j'ai vu un jour une devanture de boucher
le discours du souverain ce n'était pas
pour les bleus si nous avions mieux
réfléchi nous aurions appris à jouer à
des jeux à la main chaude au loup ou sa
perche et les jeux c'est bon pour les
enfants
moi il me semble que j'aimerais
alors les petites dans l'espoir que le
boeuf savants se laisseraient tenter par
les plaisirs de la tap du colin maillard
et du chat perché apprirent ce jeu au
grand roux qui s'en amusent à beaucoup
et même plus qu'il n'était raisonnable
un boeuf de son âge alors je ne m'abuse
je ne comprends pas qu'on puisse à ce
point manquer de sérieux et de dignité
quand on pense que la surface d'un
rectangle s'obtient en multipliant la
longueur et la largeur et n'apportent or
je n'ai jamais rencontré le rectangle
si on jouait plutôt à pigeon vole je
suis incapable de m'intéresser à des
sottises
ces fouilles qui a chaud un son salon
mais est bientôt les deux boeufs ne
purent plus supporter et formèrent le
plus mauvais attelage qu'on n'eût jamais
vu quatre pattes sur quatre pattes
quatre pattes sont bons quatre pattes
reste qu'est ce que c'est hall est pas
là pour nos deux villes la ligne droite
est elle bien le plus court chemin de
points avec ses boeufs me feront perdre
la tête
si seulement je pouvais les banques il
faut pas espérer le vendre le blanc il
est de plus en plus maigres et d'autre
part si je me débarrasse du grand ou qui
est devenue insupportable
qu'est ce que je ferais d'un seul
comédie leboeuf blanc le problème
semblait insoluble
mais quelques jours après le maître
décida par les robots
[Musique]
et les bleus j'ai à vous parler am stram
gram pic et pic et colégram h te
conseille de finir tessin jeu rigolo on
peut plus jouer maintenant
ne te nourrit pas pour ça quant à toi
boeuf blanche ordonne de ne plus penser
qu'à qu'on travaille doucement
j'admets que vous vous adressiez avec
cette rudesse un boeuf finhan ces
espèces ne comprennent points et
d'autres langages
mais ce n'est pas ainsi que l'on traite
un boeuf instruit à boeufs instruit
parfaitement instruits dans les sciences
les belles lettres et la philosophie
mais trouvez-vous convenable qu'un boeuf
de mon mérite soit obligé aux travaux de
la terre vous me reprochez de fer au
chant de mauvaises besogne mais c'est
que je suis fait pour accomplir d'autres
travaux plus importants
tu as raison mais c'est bien fini
j'entends que désormais tu restes à la
maison pour h m is études dans la
quiétude la plus complète
j'aime voir aux belles lettres aux
sciences et à la philosophie un visage
bien joufflues n'est donc pas d'autres
soucis que d'étudier de manger et de
dormir
legrand ou travaillera pour deux un
grand ou ne me demandez pas ce que j'en
pense
vous vous pensez sans doute que le
maître des boeufs aimer les animaux
savants vous vous trompez ce n'était
qu'un mâle un inactif et bien nourri le
buzz blanc en grèce a rapidement et
repris sa bonne mine
certes il continuait de penser beaucoup
mes pensées ne fait pas maigrir il était
en possession d'une belle philosophie
lorsque son maître s'aperçut qu'il avait
progressé de 75 kg il décida alors de le
vendre au boucher en même temps que le
grand roux qui n'avaient pas renoncé à
jouer hors de propos je vais conduire
les bleus chez le boucher
il faut que chacun reste à sa place les
boeufs devant la charrue et les savants
devant leur libre laissez-nous mois les
accompagner si vous voulez sauf
la mort n'est rien il est philosophe la
mort d'un philosophe peut-être plus en
temps on loue joue une marche funèbre
tu fais encore des illusions c'est la
musique d'un cirque
[Musique]
entrez entrez la représentation va
commencer le grossiste mondial
mondialement célèbre à l'honneur de vous
présenter les attractions les plus
explorée à aubière le plus grenat du
monde le plus petit géant du monde
[Musique]
une dame qui joue seul au piano à quatre
mains direct un bonjour mademoiselle
vous voulez deux places non on voudrait
nous vendre de bus c'est pour mon
déjeuner c'est trop c'est cela justement
qu'un ministre ça me paraît impossible
et autres koné pièce de jeu tout est
bien de petites vies il va pas vous les
vendra en quoi exactement comment
boucher
ouah la paire me paraît intéressante
d'accord et le grand circuit mondial a
encore l'honneur de vous présenter une
paire de boeufs
je vais vous parler du principe
d'archimède ensuite avec mon camarade
nous ferons une partie de pâtes chaudes
et les parents achetèrent une autre
paire de boeufs mais les petites se
gardèrent bien de leur apprendre à lire
car elle savait maintenant qu'à moins de
trouver place dans un cirque les boeufs
ne gagne rien à s'instruire